well jacob of course two straight
uh cy young awards uh back to back uh
won his last five out of six against
this marlin team and i agree with
anthony recker
this is an important game to win this
rubber match of this series against this
first place
marlin team nine pitches a hundred or
better
those last two starts after throwing
just one pitch 100 or better his entire
career before that
at age 32 he is only adding velocity
not losing it second inning jacob the
ground faces brian anderson leading off
for the marlins
jake's only walked three batters in 18
innings over his first
three plus starts and anderson takes out
side ball four so a four pitch walk to
anderson leading
off the second inning here's matt joyce
joy's two for five in the series
oh boy four pitch walk how about that
eight pitches eight balls and degrom has
walked the first two hitters in the
second here's eddie alvarez
still looking for his first big league
hit the former olympic speed skater
has gone over nine in his big league
career again the 3-2
it's hit sharply and davis with a
sprawling stop but he has no play
eddie alvarez has his first major league
hit
jd davis probably saved a run by
smothering that ball
but couldn't make a play and now the
trainer brian chiclo
is coming out my goodness and there is
some concern
about to ground and there it is that
middle finger
possibly not enough concern for him to
come out of the game or even throw a
warm-up pitch in a big spot here with
the bases loaded and two out
again the o2 and vr gets a curveball and
grounds it to second
and jimenez takes care of it and degrom
finds his way through he throws his
first curveball tonight to get vr out
with the bases loaded
and keep it scoreless andres simenes
playing second base today
batting eighth in the order leading off
in the home third against pablo lopez
jimenez lines one tour in the middle
he's got his first hit in this series
and the mets first hit of the day so
jimenez starts the home third with a
lead-off single
as tomas nito steps in there he goes he
takes off the throw by lavorn way and
jimenez slides in safely
with his third career stolen base
and he draws a walk so the mets of the
first two man on the eight and nine
hitters getting the board against pablo
lopez
three and oh to nimo and taking all the
way it's ball four and the mets of the
bases loaded and the mets with the
golden chance here with their big
hitters coming up
bases loaded nobody out mcneil then
alonso
and mcneil hits what toward the whole
snag beautifully by alvarez out at
second
safe at first as a run comes home but
eddie alvarez
with the magnificent stop they get the
force on nemo for the first out
jimenez comes home with the game's first
run and it's one nothing new york
terrific
play by alvarez so now conforto with
first and third and two on
and he flares that one to left on comes
dickerson coming in
i think he can't make the catch he boxes
it around
neato scores mcneal to third conforto's
gonna have to hold it first in the midst
of a two-nothing lead
andres has the only met hit today he's
single to center to start the third
that's hammered down to first and it
gets by aguilar and down the line
jimenez on his way to second
as joyce plays it off the sidewall and
ximena's pulls in at second base
that ball ate up aguilar as it appeared
to have top spin going by him down the
line so
two out amen is now in third and nimble
will try and get him in
line the other way and nemo will drive
in the run
so nimmo not wasting any time strokes a
base hit to left field to bring in
jimenez
and the mets now lead three nothing i'm
john bertie
well birdie turns around 98 sends it
right back up the middle and birdie gets
the based hit
let's see if jesus aguilar can do
something here with two outs
two for five with a double in his career
against degrom
and this is a high drive deep to left
field is it gonna oh it is gonna get
out a two run home run for jesus aguilar
and the marlins are
right back in the ball game well the big
man has
done it again what a start to his 2020.
two pitches two hits here's nimmo and
nimmo's hit by the pitch and that'll
load the bases so now mcneil they're
gonna play the middle infielders halfway
with the bases loaded nobody out mcneal
lifts one to shallow center
jimenez with good speed at third will
tag harrison makes the catch jimenez is
coming
the throw by harrison is way up the line
and jimenez scores easily on the
sacrifice fly by mcneil
and it's now 4-2 new york 2-2 coming
lifted to left chasing back mcneal to
the warning track it's over his head and
off the wall levarnway to third he's
going to be held up there
alvarez pulls into second base with his
first major league extra base hit
his third hit of the day here's where it
gets dicey right here
game on the line 26th pitch of the
inning upcoming
he struck him out diaz blows away
harrison
who takes the golden sombrero and diaz
works through
trouble in the top of the eight birdies
on base for the third time and now
dickerson
who's one for four had an opposite field
single back in the first
and dickerson hits one to short should
be two the step and throw by rosario and
the ball game is over
lugo gets the double play from dickerson
and the mitts take the rubber
game of the series from the marlins